en el vídeo anterior vimos un concepto
que es de los más profundos en
estadística y se trata del teorema del
límite central y la razón por la que es
tan genial es que si ustedes tienen
cualquier distribución con una media y
una varianza bien definida de hecho aquí
puse la desviación estándar pero tiene
que ser la media y una varianza bien
definido aquí no importa como sea esta
distribución puedo tomar muestras como
se vio en el vídeo pasado aquí la
muestra de tamaño n igual a 4 y
literalmente tome 4 instancias de este
conjunto este es un ejemplo tome su
media y considere esta como la media de
la muestra al menos esta para mi primera
muestra sé que es un poquito confuso
considere esta muestra considere cada
uno de los miembros de esta muestra para
encontrar su media y después saqué la
media de esta muestra y seguía siendo
esto una y otra vez en una segunda
muestra obtuve estos valores de
elementos aleatorios en esta
distribución encontré el promedio
la media de la muestra lo genial del
teorema del límite central es que
conforme voy graficando el valor medio
de las muestras encuentro algo que se
aproxima a la distribución normal y esto
funciona mejor para aproximarnos a la
distribución normal conforme n se hace
más grande y para poder comprender la
terminología esta distribución de
frecuencia que acabo de dibujar aquí
abajo
o aquí o aquí
eso se llama y es algo confuso porque
usamos la palabra muestra o muestreo muy
seguido
se llama la distribución de muestreo
de la media de la muestra
y la distribución de muestreo de la
media de la muestra
y vamos a explicar un poco esto para que
se comprenda de qué trata este concepto
cuando decimos que es la distribución de
la muestra nos dice que está siendo
derivado de la distribución de alguna
estadística que en este caso se refiere
a la media de la muestra y la estamos
derivando de muestras de la distribución
así que si ésta es mi primera muestra
con un tamaño de muestra de 4 uso la
media como estadística puede haber usado
alguna otra estadística como la moda o
el promedio aunque la distribución de la
muestra de la media de la muestra es la
más común y en mi opinión esa es la
mejor manera de aprender sobre el
teorema del límite central e incluso
sobre la distribución de muestreo y
vamos a probar esto de manera
experimental no de manera matemática yo
pienso que el experimentar es mucho más
satisfactorio en estadística
y esto tiene la misma media la misma
media
que nuestra distribución original como
la que estoy mostrando aquí es la misma
media veremos en el siguiente vídeo que
esto va a comenzar a aproximarse a una
distribución normal aún cuando mi
distribución original sea diferente y es
lo que haremos con esta sección de acá y
para dar crédito a quien le corresponde
esto lo obtuve de la siguiente dirección
online start book puntocom que es una
aplicación bastante buena pues ayuda a
visualizar los muestreos de esta
distribución y aquí puedo crear de hecho
mi propia distribución vamos a hacer
algo loco por acá en teoría pueden usar
esto con una función de densidad de
probabilidad discreta o continua pero lo
que tenemos aquí es uno de 32 valores y
vamos a establecer las diferentes
probabilidades para cada uno de estos 32
valores
claramente se puede ver que esto no es
una distribución normal lo que quiero
hacer primero es usar una simulación
para comprender o para comprender mejor
de qué se trata la distribución de
muestreo lo que voy a hacer ahora es
comenzar con una muestra de cinco a la
vez el tamaño de mi muestra es de cinco
y cuando le dé clic a animated se van a
tomar cinco muestras de esta función de
distribución de probabilidad y esas
cinco muestras las van a ver cuando dé
clic acá va a encontrar el promedio y va
a dibujar la media y si le doy clic acá
lo volverá a hacer de nuevo aquí podemos
ver cómo toma cinco muestras y saca el
promedio y lo pone acá
ubs que hice aquí vaya voy a tener que
limpiar esto vamos a hacerlo de nuevo
doy clic aquí
5 muestras
saca la media la dibuja acá vamos a
hacerlo de nuevo 5 muestras de esta
función de distribución de probabilidad
y la gráfica acá saca la media y la
gráfica acá puedo seguir haciendo esto
aunque me lleve tiempo puedo hacerlo nos
unas mil veces por ejemplo aquí ya tengo
un botón donde tiene hacer estos mil
veces y déjenme aclarar que este
programa está realmente generando los
números aleatorios de acuerdo con esta
distribución que puse acá va a tomar 5 a
la vez encontrar su media y dibujarla
acá si le doy clic al botón de 10.000 va
a hacer esto diez mil veces cinco a la
vez encontrando su media y graficando la
que vamos a hacer justamente eso y vamos
a ver qué nos muestra aquí está y noten
que ya aparece bastante a una
distribución normal y como les había
comentado la media de mi distribución
loca era 14.45 y la media después de
haber hecho 10 mil veces el muestreo es
de 14.42 que es pues bastante similar a
la media de mi distribución original
y el sesgo y curtósis son elementos que
nos ayudan a ver la forma que tiene esta
distribución al saber qué tan normal es
nuestra distribución y hemos hablado al
respecto en vídeos anteriores pero vamos
a tomarnos un momento para recordar un
poco de sus conceptos aquí son conceptos
bastante directos el sesgo lo que nos
dice que buenos voy a dibujar en un
color diferente si esta fuera una
distribución normal perfecta más o menos
así
si es una distribución perfecta esta
tendría un sesgo de cero si tuviéramos
un sesgo positivo tendríamos una cauda
hacia la derecha más larga
más o menos así esta sería la
distribución con un sesgo positivo sesgo
positivo que la hace un poquito menos
ideal que la forma de una distribución
normal y un sesgo negativo se vería al
contrario la cauda sería larga hacia la
izquierda
este es un sesgo negativo así pues algo
que no tiene ni sesgo positivo ni
negativo es esta forma normal ideal
simétrica alrededor de la media
ahora la curtósis que suena una palabra
bastante sofisticada en realidad el
concepto no es tan sofisticada y de
nuevo si yo dibujara una distribución
normal perfecta en diferente color y
recuerden no tenemos una sola
distribución normal se pueden tener
diferentes medias y diferentes
desviaciones estándar
o menos así en nuestra distribución
normal si yo tuviera una curtósis
positiva que pasaría a bueno voy a tener
acá bodas más gordas vas a bajar
dibujarla más o menos así y tendríamos
simas muy picudas vamos a dibujar lo
mejor caudas gordas y simas picudas
mucho más picudas que la distribución
normal esto de aquí es una corta
dispositiva y dependiendo de qué tan
positiva sea será más picuda la cima de
esta distribución una curtósis negativa
va a tener causas más pequeñas pero va a
estar mucho más suave hacia el medio
hacia el centro va a ser más o menos
algo así
esto tendrá una curtósis negativa y
quizás en otros vídeos vamos a explicar
esto con más detalle en el contexto de
esta simulación la curtósis y el sesgo
nos dicen que tan normal es esta
distribución así que cuando el tamaño de
nuestra muestra es igual a 5 pero
tenemos esta distribución muy cercana a
la normal vamos a hacer otra prueba con
10.000 iteraciones y vemos que todavía
tienen un poco de sesgo y un poco de
curtósis veamos qué pasa cuando tenemos
una muestra un poco más grande y lo
podemos hacer de manera simultánea aquí
tengo mi muestra igual a 25 elementos
vamos a por toda la media distribución
media voy a hacer una animación con mi
simulación con 5 muestras y aquí voy a
tomar 25 muestras encuentro cuáles son
media y la dibujo acá abajo
aquí volvemos a repetir esta animación
aquí tenemos nuestra muestra de 5 y aquí
nuestra muestra de 25
obtenemos la media y se muestra acá
y lo que acabo de hacer lo voy a hacer
unas 10.000 veces con este botón y eso
es interesante recuerden que nuestra
distribución original no tenían nada que
ver con la normal
una vez que hicimos esto
observé muy bien poco aquí en la
pantalla aquí lo interesante es que
ambas distribuciones pues se parecen a
la normal pero si se fijan en el sesgo y
la curtósis cuando nuestra muestra es
mayor es mucho más normal es mucho más
parecido a una normal perfecta cuando
tenemos una muestra más grande vemos que
esta distribución es mucho más parecida
a una distribución normal simétrica y
veremos en futuros vídeos que esto no es
sólo normal sino que también está
bastante cercana a la media y pueden
pensar porque es que esto tiene sentido
pues si nuestra muestra es mayor tenemos
más oportunidad de obtener valores
alejados de la media es menor ya que es
muy poco probable que tengamos nuestras
25 muestras muy lejanas de estas partes
yo tendrían valor es más o menos bien
distribuidos en todo este rango por lo
que nuestra distribución tiende a ser
más parecida a la normal ya veremos más
al respecto de esto en el futuro
espero que con esto ustedes queden
satisfechos con la explicación
experimental de que el problema del
límite central se aplica a cualquier
distribución aunque sea una distribución
tan loca como esta y pueden usar esta
aplicación que la pueden encontrar en
online state book puntocom para
experimentar con todo tipo de
distribuciones y ver que esto se sigue
cumpliendo y recordemos que lo
interesante de esto es que conforme voy
a aumentando mi muestra mi distribución
se va apareciendo mucho más a la normal